Stephen I wanted to ask you
what was like for you
revisiting your own past day after day I
I presume that not only do the actors
look like your family Gabriel definitely
looks like you in the film
but the the environments were they
similar to what you remember from
growing up
yeah yeah
it was it was a coffee experience
especially especially casting the Fable
men's because I was I was casting this
based on people I knew pretty well
and um and it was that's what sort of
make made it difficult because the first
difficult thing was deciding to tell the
story in the first place that was
probably the the hardest challenge in in
the sense that you know this is my
private life and I leave a little bit of
myself we all do behind in everything we
we perform in or write or direct or
produce we leave a little of ourselves
behind
um and so all of my films I consider to
be personal films but I've never really
made a movie that is about a lived
experience as opposed to just a metaphor
to something else and so this was it
almost took the pandemic of having two
years of doing nothing for me to have a
chance for Tony and I to get on Zoom and
talk about the feasibility of actually
telling the story of of uh a
coming-of-age story and it was also
really wicked weird to walk onto a set
and actually walk into my house from
1958. your old bedroom my old bedroom
the kitchen the living room the the
menorah in the right place the battle
like against the wall I mean it was
really you know Rick Carter who was a
production designer
um went back and we have all these
family pictures and and eight millimeter
movies and videos of my life in those
days so Rick really you know rebuilt the
environment Tony can you talk to me
about writing the screenplay you said
you did it on Zoom during the pandemic
uh we've already we've done a
conversation I've written an article for
Vanity Fair uh from an interview with
the both of you and you talked about uh
Tony that over the years you had said
that should be a movie uh every time he
would tell you uh an anecdote from his
childhood uh what was it like getting to
that point where you said actually yes
this will be a movie and and will you
write it with me
I mean I think I think what happened we
we sort of edged our way into it uh
slowly over the years
um and after West Side Story was done
not before it was released but after it
was done
we began to kind of get serious about
I interviewed you a lot and got uh we
made long lists of
of his very very busy childhood he
wasn't he's always been a very busy
person uh and uh we we had way way too
much I mean enough for like six movies
uh and we we always knew what the center
was going to be
um and what the film would focus on
primarily we worked for one summer just
sort of writing out a long Pro's
Narrative of it and then uh the early
fall
playing with outlines and then one day
Steven said well tomorrow let's get on
Zoom and start writing and I
it was today let's start writing today
no no listen to today because I had this
impression that why don't we just put
fade in why don't we start with fade in
most movies start with fade in and we
just sort of I don't think we my
impression was we didn't make an
appointment to start writing the script
it just started to all it would come out
it would have been smart of you to do
that because I was I usually take like
three or four four years before I start
writing just to kind of warm up clear my
throat and
adjust the pencils on the desk and
everything and you know he was uh
three days a week four hours a day
pretty much exit to the on the clock
um and then I think to both are shocked
uh shocks uh we finished the first draft
in two months and then started doing
rewrites and and everything happened I
mean it just sort of flowed out it was
really it was it was a fascinating thing
I had never written anything with
anybody
and uh I didn't know how whether it
would work one of the things that really
was sort of a astonishing to me is how
it kind of brought my mom and dad back I
had just lost my father a year before
and I lost my mom three years before and
so when this happens to all of us we're
kind of orphaned and and it was a really
interesting
process of recapturing through memory
and through actually the physical act of
creating scenes based on those memories
and uh then being able to invite my
sisters and Sue and Nancy to share these
memories with us by giving them the
first draft script to read and and
getting cooperation about this this
really happened that way do you remember
it exactly like this and getting that
kind of corroboration from from the from
my sisters and it it was obviously the
most personal thing I've ever been close
to in my life and it was difficult
because of that it was very difficult
also since the last scene of the movie
that's in the movie that uh Paul's in uh
we didn't plan it this way it just so
happened but the last scene that um that
Paul did as Bert with um Gabriel as
Sammy the scene in the apartment in
Brentwood was on the day of the one year
anniversary of my father's passing
and when none of us knew this until
someone pointed it out to us that day so
Michelle and Paul when you're playing uh
a person who's in you know Mitzi and
bird are fictionalized versions of uh
Leah and Arnold but but were there
questions you had for Stephen about who
they were or what they were like what
kind of conversations did you have with
him as you were finding the characters
oh well it started from the moment that
we met over Zoom right the it it it was
an immediate kind of spilling over of
stories and Recollections and just
sharing and sharing and sharing and and
it was that way it was that way it
continues to be that way
um so it you know I don't questions
arose but there was already so much in
front of us to absorb and to sit with
you know so it it began from the moment
that we spoke
yeah I think Steven's uh vulnerability
frankly and openness you know opened the
door for all of us I think including the
crew to to bring that part of ourselves
to to work
um and I should also say that the the
the script that Stephen and Tony wrote
was was beautiful I mean Michelle and I
had said to each other you know how
lucky are we you know that this is the
language you know these are the words
that that we get to work with
um so Not only was Stephen there for us
in every open-hearted step about his
life his family we also had beautiful
characters on the page to sort of bring
together
um Steven's memories his life who are
Bert and Mitzi and who are Michelle and
Paul and and where do those things meet
because I think that's the only way to
to Really capture
um the essence of who Bert and Mitzi are
is not through any kind of trying to
please a memory or
um but uh but but where do we all meet
this together and what are we making
together
Gabriel I I was curious I've heard that
you had uh after you went through a
number of auditions to get the part then
you started uh interrogating Stephen is
that right that you just had a lot of
questions for him uh tell me about the
research you did
to play a version of the person who's
directing you uh well
I get this script about a week after I
had been cast and
I remember spending that week incredibly
nervous that I would be
um unprepared and so I'm just watching
all of his movies and and trying to get
as much you know old interviews and
stuff and then when I get the script the
script is so dense and
perfect and every word has a very very
specific meaning every letter
literally and there's just so much input
that it's I mean regardless of it being
a real person it I I have to talk about
it with someone and the glory of it is
that
these this character is based off of him
so every scene that would happen did
this really happen it did okay what did
what did you feel what did you think how
did your perspective change what did you
think of how did relationships change
who did you think of these people
um and
I tried to do that as much as possible
maybe one or two times a week
um and uh
and and and yeah and sometimes he would
tell me and sometimes he wouldn't and
he'd want me to figure it out because
yes it's based off of him but at the
same time it's Sammy and not
uh Stephen we could hang out and talk
about the movie but then also just get
to know each other and and
um because we also couldn't meet each
other in person it was 2021 and I hadn't
been vaccinated yet and you needed to be
fully vaccinated before going on to set
legally and
um I in Canada for my age group I was
just eligible for my first vaccine which
um back then the requirement was three
weeks until you get your second dose but
in the states it's two weeks so I got to
uh
do a little loophole so I could start so
I could be there on time and and and
start filming it so I didn't meet him
until uh we were both on set together
Judd I wanted to start by asking you
about a very famous role from earlier in
your career Alex on Taxi was the
straight man he was surrounded by all
these colorful characters and and in
this movie you get to be the colorful
character the big purple rose on the
birthday cake as Uncle surrounded
everything myself
there was no there was nobody else you
know what I mean tell me about playing
this wild card who comes in and and
stirs up this young man's life yeah
it was a puzzle
um
well Stephen I don't I don't know how
the hell he got to me but I
what could you possibly have seen that
I've done that anything like that unless
it was um because Independence Day
okay
okay
among everything else you've ever I was
I was responsible for saving the world
yes Stephen when Stephen called me and
and told me that the character was such
I had no idea what I was going to play
because I didn't get the script yet so
uh
I said well okay
um where does he come from and he said
he could he said he was sort of guessing
he said he can he can come from
Ukraine right and this was a real man in
your life yeah was he really named Uncle
Boris his name his real name was Uncle
Boris yeah he didn't change that but but
if if you heard that conversation I'm
not quite sure I believed him I thought
it was fictional I really did when I
looked at it and I met Gabriel I said
I'm gonna destroy this boy and
that my partners to tell him that
horrible things are going to happen to
him
even though it has to happen so I walked
out of there and I said who the hell am
I some Oracle the came from some place
right it sounds like that it sounds like
so the last thing I said to Stephen when
we're believing I said thanks for
parachuting me into this movie and
because it felt that way you know an
oracle comes and sits in the kid's room
and takes him apart and tells him and he
has to be a director well that's what
it's like being a kid is these older
people in your life can be kind of
mythological in a way and the film
closes with one such encounter with John
Ford and Sammy which is a real
experience you had
uh yeah I think I think we saw the story
so you don't have to retell the story
but can you talk to us about casting
John Ford and and David Lynch and how
that all came about well you know it was
something that I wanted to that's how we
wanted to end the story and the film
that was the end of that segment of
Sammy's life
and um and I didn't know who I was going
to cast for John Ford I think Tony and I
were discussing a number of
possibilities and then Tony's husband
Mark Harris said what about David Lynch
and so I owe that I owe it all to Mark
Harris
getting him to say yes was another
matter well what's that story well it
just took a while because David wasn't
really interested in appearing in front
of the camera as much as he has done
great work behind the camera and it took
it took a lot of phone calls a lot of
controlling and took a good friend of
his Laura Dern that did a Mitzvah by
calling him several times to say You
must do this and then the only thing he
asked for when he finally agreed to do
it he said all I want all I'm going to
ask for is I want to have the costume
two weeks before I shoot because I want
to wear it every day
and he wanted uh Cheetos and his uh in
his dressing room
and and when he left Cheetos and when he
left he asked if he could take it there
was still a lot left in the bag and he
very politely said can I take these home
with me
so I think it's worth it absolutely
that's that scene ever since I've seen
the film a couple of months ago has
changed the way I take photographs so
thank you very much
uh thank you all for joining us tonight
uh let's hear it for Stevenson thank you
very much thank you Williams Paul Dino
Gabriel LaBelle and Judd hurt